welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and whilst it
seems like Marvel movies are aimed
solely out of Western demographic with
heroes like Captain America taking
center stage throughout the MCU there's
actually a lot that Disney do to make
their movies marketable to the rest of
the world throughout this video I'll be
breaking down all of the changes that
Disney made in the international
releases to make sure that each country
that the films were shown in had their
own versions of scenes that catered to
their interests this has been ongoing
for years and these my new details are
awesome little additions for fans of
film trivia who want to know why the
film's have such worldwide appeal
without the way thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into my
breakdown of all the MCU details that
were changed to appeal to other
countries first up is Iron Man 3 which
upon its release in China got a massive
four minutes of added footage that
pretty much contained a lot of product
placement as well as two of the
country's biggest stars the new scenes
are dotted throughout the movie and one
revolves around Iron Man's operation at
the end of the film in which he has the
arc reactor taken out of his chest and
it features Bing Bing fan who has seen
briefly in the standard versions as well
as Suki Wang who plays dr. Wu the movie
actually opens with the words flashing
on screen what does Iron Man rely on to
revitalize his energy before the message
coolio duo
pops up which is a popular brand of milk
in China whoo in some totally natural
product placement then appears on screen
drinking the milk Chinese electronic
manufacturers are also seen throughout
the film and there's a scene in which
happy Hogan cheers on Chinese
schoolchildren alongside Iron Man the
movie becomes a pretty big advert to
show some of the major products and I'm
kind of glad that the movie didn't turn
into a big milk advert for other
audiences but whilst I am on the subject
actually did you know that ghuli audio
is an outstanding product that I used to
revitalize my energy when making video
card stock now next up is guardians of
the galaxy now guardians of the galaxy
seems like a pretty straightforward name
for a team that's made up of a talking
raccoon
and a living tree but I guess that the
Taiwan branch of Disney thought that it
didn't really sum up the group as best
as occurred so ever since its release in
the country the Guardians have instead
been known as something that roughly
translates the interplanetary unusual
attacking team I guess I guess this kind
of makes more sense dessert as suppose
they are in the planetary they are a bit
unusual and they are an attacking team
so yeah I really don't know but hey I
guess the name stuck because the film
went on to be a huge success over there
and I'm gonna be referring to the
Guardians as that from now on so yeah
and now on to Doctor Strange
whitewashing another big change for
Eastern audiences came with Doctor
Strange and the whitewashing of the
sorcerer supreme who made a lot of
headlines at the time with the original
Tibetan monk being recast as tilda
swinton it turns out that this was
carried out by Disney because they
didn't want to offend China who don't
actually recognize Tibet as an
independent country they also gender
swap the character to its M god damn
sjw's in it this is political
correctness gone mad I tell you what's
next a female Thor anyway Swinton
actually went over very well and it's
safe to say that the casting choice has
now been embraced by many especially the
Chinese market and finally we go to
Captain America in the scene in which
Sam tells cap about missing out on
Marvin Gaye's troubled man album cap
notes it down in his list of things to
catch up on and depending on what
country you saw the film in massively
changed the list the u.s. got things
like Steve Jobs and the Berlin Wall
whereas France got their 98 World Cup
win Daft Punk the fifth element and
Louis defines the UK got the World Cup
final from 1966 yeah I know it was
pretty long ago yeah but we'll never
forget it's like the last good thing
that we've done yet so stick it in the
book on second thoughts I don't really
know why Captain America would care
about that or France now yeah but hey
Marvel need to make those sweet pounds
and euros somehow Disneyland Paris won't
pay for itself and that's our entire
list are there any other changes that
you've heard of that should have made it
and do you agree that ghuli order is the
best milk on the
it if not the galaxy comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the news that Tom Holland originally
had a scene in venom but Disney made
Sony cut it which will be linked at the
end I go over everything you need to
know about it as well as why it was cut
so make sure you check it out after this
if you want to come talk to me about
movies TV shows games and comic books
and you can follow me on twitter at
definition whitey it's the best way to
get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully i see you over
there after this i also just wanna let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of john with three on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is i like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
MCU changes in the comments section
below the winner will be chosen at
random on September the 10th and the
bureau will be shipped out from them
till they get to the prize it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is a channel for people who are super
into superheroes so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]